Key objective data
are increasingly available,
from low costs wearable devices,
like the Fitbit activity monitor, or
even sensors embedded in smartphones.
When combined with apps on the phone,
they can create a patient
self management system.
That often includes the ability for
family members or caregivers,
to monitor the status
of an elderly relative.
They're becoming more
sophisticated over time, and
the US Food and
Drug Administration is currently
grappling with the degree to which they
should be regulated as medical devices.
AliveCor's smart phone case, that
can monitor a patient's heartbeat is
a good example of a sophisticated device
that has been through the FDA process.
This process is designed to assure
things such as, the devices are safe,
they won't injure the patient.
They accurately measure what they claim,
as compared to earlier devices.
They're manufactured properly and that
the manufacturer keeps records, so that
patients with a potentially defective
device can be readily identified.